Hello, I'm Brett Morgan from
the Google Maps Developer
Relations team here in Sydney.
This week, I'd like to show
you how to add custom
InfoWindows with the Google
Maps SDK for iOS.
InfoWindows give contextually
relevant information to your
users quickly and painlessly.
Time to dive in.
Here, we have the code for
Google Map integration in an
iOS application.
As you can see, I'm configuring
the map for point
of interest by declaring a
serial location coordinate
2-D. I construct the GMS
Marker for the point of
interest at the center of
the map view and add the
Marker to the map.
Note, I've set the title
attribute as the Marker.
And this will bring out our
default InfoWindow rendering
when a user taps
on the Marker.
Let's have a look at
that in action.
Now, this is pretty good and
really, really easy.
But sometimes, you want
to display more
than just simple text.
If your application is about
real estate sales, you could
show the expected sales price.
If you're building a cinema
application, why not show
which movies are showing
at the cinema today?
For these cases, a
custom InfoWindow
is the perfect thing.
I'm going to build a custom
InfoWindow that shows a photo
at a point of interest.
I have a .png asset here that
uses the background for the
InfoWindow and a photo of
the Sydney Opera House.
I need to do a series
of steps here.
First, I'll construct a new NIB
file to configure how the
UI image and UI labels
are laid out.
Then I'll create a new UIView
subclass called
CustomInfoWindow that will
act as the binding
type for the NIB file.
Finally, I will configure the
UILabels and load the photo
the Opera House into the
InfoWindow when the user taps
on the Marker.
So let's create the NIB file,
selecting View as the template.
Name the file InfoWindow.
This brings up Interface
Builder.
Reconfigure the size of the
UIView to match the underlying
ping asset that we are using as
the InfoWindow background.
For this one, it's 224 points
wide by 221 points high.
Then we add a UIImageView to
host the InfoWindow's custom
background.
Next, we add and configure a
pair of UILabels, one to act
as a point of interest title and
the other as the address.
Next, we add in UIImageView
to display the photo.
Now, we create a new class.
Name this file CustomInfoWindow.
This creates the matching
header and
implementation files.
We add the IB outlets matching
the UILabels and UIImageView
that we configured in the
Interface build up.
Back to InfoWindow New File.
We can now configure the custom
class that this new
file is going to construct.
We can wire up the IB outlets
to their matching
configurations in
the new file.
And now, going back to our
ViewController, we need to
make sure this file is acting as
a delegate of our MapView.
We can do that by declaring
that the ViewController
conforms to the GMS MapView
delegate protocol,
MViewController.h.
Next, we instantiate the
CustomInfoWindow using NS
bundles, load NIB named
owner option selector.
And then configure the return
instance with the name of our
point of interest, along with
the photos we have to really
show it off.
So what have we just done?
We started with the Google Maps
for iOS application with
a default Marker.
Then we configured a custom
InfoWindow in Interface
Builder using a custom
background image and with
additional information over and
above the default title,
subtitle combination.
Finally, we configured our
ViewController to conform with
our GMSMapViewDelegate
protocol.
So we could construct the custom
InfoWindow from our new
file and hand it back to the
MapView when the user taps on
the Marker.
I'm hoping this quick
introduction to custom
InfoWindows has shown you a way
to add personality to your
iOS application and empower your
users to get the most out
of your app quickly and
painlessly by presenting
geographically relevant
information without the need
to take the user away
from the map.
If you have any questions about
what we have covered
here today, please feel free to
reach out to us, either on
Google+ or on Stack Overflow.
Thank you very much
for your time.